all right so hello everyone I'm Daniel
so right now I am currently a data
engineer slash research associate at my
lab which is the socialist decision
analytics lab at Virginia Tech it's part
of the bio complexity Institute
I am also currently a PhD student so I'm
trying to juggle working and fulfilling
in PhD and I totally understand why some
people will end up taking almost forever
trying to finish their PhD now and I
guess and my mom's there so like I'm
really like not making this easy for
myself so I guess my research question
is really leveraging government
administrative and open datasets for use
for Public Health mainly because I have
master's in public health and
epidemiology from Columbia University
yeah one of my performer professors is
also out here - dr. Melanie wall so
she's out there and I do work for a
Jared Lander and a lot of the I guess
experience from standing up here and
talking to people comes from the carpet
fries which is a software and data
carpentry and I also have one data camp
class that's out and I'm recording one
on Sunday so there's that and so the
first thing I want to say is Thanks so
this isn't the end of the talk banks
this is uh this is a thanks to you know
the community to all you guys I'm saying
y'all because I'm currently at school in
the south and so so first of all to our
stats NYC it's pretty much how I got my
beginnings of how to learn everything
presenting and just just constantly
learning when I moved down to DC there
was the data community DC thing which
was essentially when I went down was how
do I find what I had in New York down in
the DC / Virginia area and then there's
everyone else that I've met along the
way the PI data community sigh PI has
been really awesome they have their
conference every year in Austin Texas
and then last but not least there's the
carpentry which you know those of you
who don't know me I do a lot of teaching
and this is actually where all of my
teaching experience well most of them
come from and so yes this this book this
thing happened as you can see there was
like a tweet from 2016 so that it was
like a many a year endeavor this is a
picture that my sister drew and I'm
posting a tweet mainly because like she
doesn't own that picture anymore so I I
didn't know how the how to post of
rights of that picture but so there we
go
so this talk it's called doing data
science and you know this isn't our
conference and I wrote a python book and
I'm talking to you guys but it it really
comes down to like it's really not our
versus Python just like heavily wickham
said a few days ago it's really our and
python like the two communities can
totally live together you don't have to
pick one or the other but if you are
learning pick one that you're learning
you know that your friends are learning
so you can work together because over
time you will end up learning the other
language just by meeting everyone and
being in the community and if you didn't
know I mean at the end they were also
all friends right and so if you didn't
hear this news that was posted yesterday
you know of Wes McKinney and Hadley
Wickham can work together and start a
project together and we can all
definitely be friends
alright and like even more like if I
have to say anything it's more like the
our community itself like if you've ever
seen like the old Stack Overflow
comments and tirades or snart between
Dirk and Hadley it's more like what's
wrong with our it within itself then
like this are Python thing going on
right so what what is data science so
this is a slide I sort of stole from the
Anaconda folks from the Python side and
you know they did it's a pretty good
graphic on like you know there's so many
buzzwords like what is it right and so
one of the ways you can break this down
is like you can break down tasks by what
are the actual tools you're using
so theta sine theta engineer I kind of
play both and like these days more or
less I'm working with datasets and
databases and getting everyone in my lab
the data set that they need and then
they start the process of analyzing it
and so you know there's a bunch of
overlap you know we all do similar tasks
so you know this all ends up being like
almost a continued a continuum then like
individual roles and so last year if you
weren't here I essentially took all my
experience from running to day workshops
and compressing it into a 20 minute talk
and one of the things that I did or
talked about last year was about this
paper about structuring your projects
and this is a paper by William Noble and
in this paper he does he has this figure
which is you know how to structure your
your arm projects right you know it's
very easy when you just start off that
all of your files and scripts and output
all end up in one folder and then you
end up with this problem where you have
100 files and you can't find anything
right and so he's saying that hey like
here's an academic paper so maybe people
will start doing in in academia how to
structure your projects and once you
have like a folder structure you can
start scripting it so you know there's
this reproducible science curriculum
that has a script I wrote a script and
it's really like a bash script that
creates some files and dumps a readme or
a get keep file so you can check it into
version control systems and if you
remember either chairs talk last year a
year before you can also just write all
this in are rightly you don't even have
to leave our studio to make this happen
and then so Greg Wilson which is one of
the cofounders it from software
carpentry he him and a whole bunch of
the software carpentry team they all
wrote a paper in 2014 about best
practices for scientific computing and
then they try to update it and talk 2017
for like what's good enough
but like what ended up happening they
really just talked about like hey right
functions right loops if your copy and
pasting something like 50 times to run
something 50 times you're probably doing
it wrong you know plan for mistakes
start checking other people's code if
possible version control collaborate and
they're good enough paper really just
sort of like shows you a little bit more
about how and I'm talking to you about
this mainly because my lab we run a
summer program called data science for
the public good and essentially what
happens every summer is like there's
around 15 undergraduate students who
don't know anything about our problem a
lot of them never seen this before and
then five grad students to help you know
lead various projects right and so
there's this whole like influx of people
that I mainly task to teach and so like
they stress test every part of like
what's easy to learn what's easy to do
especially if someone writes really bad
art code like you don't crash the server
for everyone and like then I get phone
calls in middle of night and then you
know that's what I have to deal with so
how do I make my life and their life
easier is really what I'm trying to talk
about and so the first thing that we've
gone over in my lab is we just moved
everything to doctor and I sort of wrote
this process so this was like about a
three year process where we moved from
virtualbox the LXE containers and now
we're working with docker and that's
just really great because when someone
does mess something up and actually more
often than not it's really me messing
things up you know you can take off the
docker container submit it back up and
you're exactly back to where you started
ready you don't have to be worried about
like well what was that command that I
ran and if you want to if you actually
want that to be permanent you know you
put it into the doctor file script and
then that will be persisted and you've
recorded all your steps for that
particular snapshot and so this is
essentially what our labs infrastructure
looks like each one of these boxes is
roughly a docker container and so we
have we use for the most part Microsoft
are open but we also have a parallel one
that's running just our and the main
reason for that is martyr self are open
comes with like the Intel math kernal
library is pre-installed you don't have
to read compile
are by yourself so that's the reason the
main reason why we're doing it and then
on top of that we have our our Steve and
our shinee server and I have a special
container just for installing our
packages that I'll talk to you about but
just like that normal paper you can
structure your struck project templates
to exactly how you need rightly that was
just a paper to just make you think
about it and so I've adapted that to
make it it's something much simpler
where you have a data folder you have a
source folder of an output folder and a
readme and everything's like in our
project cause we're in our lab and so
within data source you know this is
really a symlink to somewhere else on
the drive because you don't want to be
checking data sets into version control
and so that's the part that's
highlighted in orange and I've
essentially told my lab we just in here
create three folders original working
final where original that's where you
got the thing from you make those things
read-only you never touch that ever
again working are the things that like
this this computation took about three
hours I don't ever want to run this
again so I'll save it somewhere and then
final is like this is the data set that
I fully clean and I can fit my model
right away or I can fit a plot right
away you don't have to like redo an
analysis script or cleaning script you
can just base it off at one plot so
that's sort of what we've moved to in my
lab and so how do we install our
packages so we have this separate docker
container for our packages and so what
this lets me do is I can install in our
package for everyone because if you're
on a Linux system every single our
package is essentially compiled from
source and if you're doing install that
packages tidy verse that's gonna take
forever especially like the first day
when 20 people just got their new system
you're just sitting there waiting and
hopefully like our servers don't crash
and then here so the thing if you want
something install for everyone or we're
trying to install all of these packages
into one folder called our packages we
want that to be loaded into the order
that our looks for when you try to load
a date
load a library so it's like a path and
if you want to do it for everyone you
look for a file call our profile dot
site it's so everyone has a dot our
profile in their home directory but the
our profile site does it for everyone
and so in here we pretty much say hey
we're changing in Lib path or prepending
so we're it's right there
our packages in front of everything else
so that gets loaded first
and then what we do for trying to
install package in the arch of the
packages container I say install
packages and then this allows me to say
like if I do need a system library for
example like SVG or JPEG or something I
can put it I can test everything out in
there and it slowly build up the whole
are stacked from Microsoft our are open
to our studio to shiny and when that's
done we say docker push everything goes
to docker hub and then on our production
server we say dr. pol we get all the
brand new images down and then we turn
on and off containers as needed and load
them back up right so there's this no
recreate flag that I learned the hard
way that exists and you know if an
existing container is already running it
won't turn it off and turn it back on
because I've definitely ran this command
without it and I was like stop someone's
like compute that was like three hours
in I was like sorry so and then so
everything is running on our studio in
our lab and you know the open source
edition is great for individual use but
I'm slowly starting to realize it was
like trying to build the art pro stack
that everyone asks you have been working
so hard because now I'm like down this
rabbit hole of like all right there so
there's Engine X and like I have a
master's in public health why am I
looking at nginx
which is like a web server that helps
you know do things so we're in the
process of exploring our Studio Pro
which should probably just solve solve
many of those problems but at least for
us because we're you know trying to
avoid paying for our co Pro everyone has
their own our studio container right so
you know if you tank a container you can
just restart it and I don't have to
worry about it and that helps really
well with like if you have if you're
working with like groups to manage
permissions and stuff and then for
authorship in our lab we you know we
have overleaf and so one it's really
nice that everything overleaf and surely
tech both have real-time editing and
rendering and you can if you look under
the hood a little bit or click around
everything is
I'll get repository so you could also
work with it offline so we use overleaf
our university provides us with a pro
account but I think that just limits
like how much how many figures you can
actually upload or something but because
we're also using docker you know you can
just run Sheryl a tech on your own
machine and they have a compose file
that'll set up you know Sheryl a tech
MongoDB and Redis and you can actually
just log in on your own laptop or any
only machine play around with it and
then slowly figure out how to like
implement it in your own system and then
we have this thing where you know we you
know a lot of our coding like so back in
undergrad I did neuroscience and I was a
bench lab researcher and I've you know
gotten carpal tunnel and my thumb and so
we always had a lab notebook but now all
of our stuff is electronic so we need to
start documenting like processes like
especially when we have external clients
we want to be able to show them like
stuff and so right now our whole system
is built on Drupal because I don't know
why we picked Drupal for WordPress but
we're sort of we hired someone new to
help along and he knows Python so we're
now down this whole Python Django
wagtail stack which is a content
management system that we can like start
automating the whole like hey when you
click a new project it does all of the
backend stuff already because I really
didn't want to learn PHP because that's
what Drupal is so what are the skills
that you need get is really hard and you
know the shell or bash is the glue that
essentially will keep everything
together and so you know Greg Wilson
he's currently the head trainer at data
camp you know data cans been mentioned
many many times already and they're
essentially poke coaching the community
but he was the co-founder of software
carpentry and that's where I got my
beginnings and he wrote these two really
amazing courses because getting bash are
so essential they're totally free on
data camp for those if you want to learn
that on your own and so at the same time
I I teach for software carpentry so they
have all that free material out there as
well is that so then how do you balance
good practices with you know just
straight-up getting work done so
Titus Brown gave a talk at my University
and I have to let go meet him and
essentially like he said like just write
functions right you you don't need all
of this infrastructure to write a
function and you don't need you know
you'll read a lot about like hey
everything should be a package but like
you don't need to write a function and I
convert it into a package because then
updating the package is kind of really
annoying so you know as long as you
start writing functions and then you
think about moving it into a package as
you start using functions for your like
one project more and more you know then
you can start thinking about moving it
into a package right you don't need to
say like oh I'm writing this project
every function I need needs to go into
package like don't do that because a lot
of those functions probably won't use
again right but at least it's a function
so you can reuse it internally if you
need to but really don't like write this
in your art code right like don't set a
working directory use our projects or
something there's even like a function
that you can make people copy and paste
in our studio so they actually open in
our studio project if they're if they're
not paying attention to where they are
there's two other really amazing
packages one is called here and our
project route and essentially it will
find things for you within like a
project hierarchy so you really
shouldn't have to find set working
directory right so like I have a folder
called functions it's in this tiny
folder and I can just say here just go
find me this it's in there shiny and
there's a thing called functions just
give me a path and then I can source the
whole thing for you so you don't even
need to write like this if interactive
thing which is what I used to do all the
time and then here is just a higher
level interface for our project route
and then saving things you know you can
always save things to CSV I used to
always say hey use the base save and
load function but I actually more
recently found out that base also has
the save RDS of read RDS functions which
is actually a lot better because what
happens when you save something when you
load it back up those variables whatever
state they were in come up into your
environment so if you had another data
frame named EF and you loaded something
you just over wrote something and that's
not good so save and load so read RDS
actually lets you assign it back to a
variable of your choice so you're not
just overriding random things in your
environment without knowing and then
secrets so how do we deal with
random passwords we don't especially
don't want to put it and to get so there
is this get pass function that's pretty
generic it can call it the our studio
API to ask you for a question if you're
in our studio it'll prompt you in the
command line if you're running scripts
in the command line and then there's the
secrets library so in here there's you
know they get passed from there but in
get secret the secret library it can use
the SSH key to encrypt other things so
in my lab we use this to encrypt our
passwords so you don't have to
constantly put in username and password
when you're getting data out of a
database and that's also really useful
when you start knitting documents
because when you click knit there's no
actual way to put in user input or your
heart coding your username and password
and their note there's no reason why
like students should have my password
because they will have sudo root access
to everything so so packages you know
there is all that so that is an example
of something that we put into a package
ourselves called estelle our I haven't
moved it up the crane yet but there's a
great free book about packages that you
can read as well and then I gave a talk
about testing and then in the end I want
to talk about cookbooks so our markdown
is really really powerful when I've
given two talks about them and there is
this free reference called the our
graphics cookbook and there's also a
book accompanied with it but from the
Python world in 2015 they were having
this problem of like coming up with a
better color map right and so there's
this color map called bird this that
they made because MATLAB made a color
map called perilla and they didn't allow
anyone to use it so they really okay
let's create a room and so virtus if
you're from the Python world it's named
that first snake if you don't like
Python it's a fish if you really
attached to MATLAB is named after bird
so for this this is what virtus looks
like and it's an actual art package that
you can use for your color maps and this
is a really good color map because it's
it can print in grayscale you can its
colorblind friendly and you know Noam
Ross who is one of our speakers you know
put this together for the art community
and one thing I want to talk about is
like hey there's color maps started
thinking about you know specific color
maps for yourself for specific variables
so when you're working out
grupe you don't have to you know think
too much about what you're looking at
and there was a great talk from the
Python community as well about how an
oceanographer has specific color maps
that they put together and if you really
can't be bothered you know there's the
color Brewer which I use to just help
you pick really good color map so you
can call it you can check off like if
it's colorblind save or print friendly
and you can get like a nice color map
out of it for yourself as well and then
other things you know make cookbooks as
needed make your own flight rules
there's a really good flight rule
repository about like how you can use
git without you know just starting over
and be cloning things and then so why am
I telling all of this well from Greg
Wilson our planet needs our help and we
need good science to fix it so thanks
everyone again thank you
you